لانه في في في
فرق هائل بين الحرب البارده اثناء الحرب
البارده
الخطر الشيوعي اليساري على امريكا وعلى
المملكه كان واحد يعني كان خطر واحد كان
في في
التقاء في المصالح يعني بين بين المملكه
وبين امريكا واضافه الى ذلك دول اخرى مثل
باكستان مثلا الان الان العداء الامريكي
الروسي ما في ما في ايديولوجيه يعني ما في
ما هو خطر مثل خطر الماركسي او الخطر
الشيوعي العداء بين امريكا وبين الصين
كمان ما له علاقه بالايديولوجيا هو هو
يعني هو صراع على هيمنه اقتصاديه هيمنه في
العالم
السعوديه لم تجد تقاطع مصالح ايديولوجيه
مع الولايات المتحده في عدائها للصين او
في عد
في المملكه مثل مثل دول اخرى يعني مثل حتى
مثل حتى الهند تحاول ان تبقى على حياد من
هذا الصراع وان تستغل الفرص الموجوده في
هذا الصراع
لبناء او لابقاء علاقات مع الطرفين بس
المملكه مثلا علاقاتها الاقتصاديه اكثرها
مع الصين صحيح ولكن علاقتها استراتيجيه
والعسكريه مع الغرب فتحاول ان تبقي
الطرفين اصدقاء لها